llegar a jugar en un mundial un sueño de
cientos de niños que viven en las
favelas de Río de Janeiro entrenan
incansablemente para ser como sus ídolos
de la selección brasileña Adriano
Ronaldo Romario y vinicios Junior
salieron de estas favelas y son
Inspiración de una nueva generación de
jugadores que están entre los 5 y 15
años
Brasil siempre ha tenido estrellas del
fútbol tuvimos a Pelé a Marta en el
fútbol femenino a Ronaldinho a Neymar
en estos barrios pobres el fútbol es más
que un deporte es una forma de movilidad
social los niños y jóvenes lo ven como
una manera de salir de las favelas así
también lo ve Francisco que creó en 2019
el equipo de fútbol ferroviario Dávila
en el complejo Favela alemán un sitio
que figura con frecuencia las noticias
por ser hogar de capos de la droga y
violencia policial
el fútbol para ellos es mucho más de lo
que vemos aquí además de su dignidad y
su sueño utilizamos el fútbol como una
herramienta
una herramienta de trabajo A partir de
aquí pueden ir a la universidad
convertirse en hombres más responsables
Y eso viene de usar el fútbol como
herramientas
y también su sueño Todos quieren jugar
un mundial
en 2014 en la cercana Favela mineira
estuvo el Astro del fútbol Pelé donde se
hizo fotografías e inauguró un nuevo
campo muchos de los niños de hoy no
alcanzaron a conocerlo pero oyen
ávidamente todas las anécdotas sobre su
visita Ahora solo esperan algún día
vestir la camiseta amarilla de la
selección y son unánimes en sus
predicciones dicen que Brasil llegará a
la final será el campeón de la copa y
llevará un sexto título a casa